you
[Music]
it's my pleasure to introduce the first
keynote speaker associate professor in
the Paul Allen school of computer
science and engineering at UW as she
alters appointments in the genome
sciences department of the Pine Ridge
Electrical Engineering and the power to
fire medical informatics and medical
education she has received a ton of
awards among them an NSF Career Award
she's been named American Cancer Society
research scholar she just received her
first ro1 from NIH which is a really
huge accomplishment and she's going to
talk today about explain early I in
precision medicine thank you for the
introduction and then thank you for
inviting me so today I'm going to talk
about my group's ongoing effort on
improving interoperability of a machine
learning models to basically turn the
blackbox machine learning model into a
white box with various applications in
medicine so these days in medicine we
use machine learning in pretty much the
same way so for each patient we first
obtain a set of features and we use a
machine learning model to predict a
clinical outcome okay so obtaining such
a machine learning model which is
basically some form of mathematical
function I just you know said like F F
function and it's really quite easy
these days we all can download some
machine learning software from website
and then train the model to your
particular training data so that you
will get a good accuracy so now then is
my job down here as an AI researcher in
this domain so when you get a prediction
results like this depicted in this slide
a natural question is a why but the
model does not explain even the expert
ml expert who developed the system you
say it's AI imaging and just a trust it
okay
so the important missing piece here
isn't explanations for instance it
doesn't tell you why the features
selected by the model used by the models
makes sense also which features
contribute to the prediction these
explanations are very important
especially in clinical applications
because they can give us information
important information about appropriate
clinical actions so these led us my
group to identify the following two
problems we need to solve
we need address to advance the field of
precision medicine so how to select can
we select pre-select or learn
interpreter features to begin with and
then the features especially that are
likely to give some meaningful
explanations of the outcome and you can
use a prior knowledge to do that and
then when you use a time series data
such as data from patient monitoring
system it's a very common medical data
and we need some you know we need to
somehow transform them into a form a
machine learning model can take as input
and then we you know we want these
transform the features to also be
relevant to the prediction tasks and
still be interpret ago ok how can we do
this and sometimes we need deal with the
situation where not all features arrived
at the same time for instance let's say
that there's a trauma patient very
serious one and then some from
dispatchers report will come first some
from ER doctors or paramedics in
ambulances or ER emergency rooms come
next and the some are measured later on
and in such a case is it possible to
guide the paramedics or air doctors what
needs to be measured based on what is
available now and then yet you will also
want to have a good prediction accuracy
and and then you want it to be made in a
timely manner ideally before the patient
arrives at the hospital ok so these are
the new
new problem we have to resolve an
increment machine learning you know
current machine learning techniques you
cannot support and then oh where is the
second one so so so the second point is
really important and then it is just a
mr. from the slide I think I just
removed it okay the second the second
one is actually depicted on this slide
so and then many prediction models are
considered as just as a black box you
have an input you have an output you
have a very complicated a function and
it will be great if you can know for
each prediction result which it features
contributed the most and it can be
different for different patients so
basically you want to know the magnitude
of these 50 values if you want through
VP and then you want to make this
individualized okay so in this talk I'm
going to show you how our new
interpretable machine learning
techniques can potentially transform
important areas of a medicine so first
developing prediction and recommendation
systems in hospitals the second part of
the talk I'm going to talk about how to
enable personalize that drug selection
for individual cancer patients and then
finally I'm gonna focus on much more
poorly understood diseases such as
Alzheimer's disease for which there
aren't any drugs at all so in this case
the goal is to leverage all of the data
available data to find a molecular basis
common to general ad are Sandra's
disease which can inform drug discovery
so this techniques are developed just
the most you know these are very general
machine and techniques and can be
applied to other problems even beyond
biology or medicine and a you see that
it's a very powerful approach so our
research in my lab covers the spectrum
from basic drug discovery biology for
poorly understood disease to very
specific treatment recommendation for
better understood diseases so let's talk
about the first part so it's about
surgery in anesthesia so they are very
integral part of Health
care and then they but can't they post a
considerable risk of complications and
death sometimes so in this project we
focused on on one in the physiological
condition called hypoxemia it means low
blood oxygen level it causes a serious
of patient harm sometimes death the
number one you know the leading cause of
anesthesia related deaths death
so if hypoxemia can be predicted before
it occurs then anesthesiologist can take
actions to proactively prevent hypoxemia
and minimize the patient harms for that
we developed a new machine learning
system we named it prescient and then it
can predict near-term risk of hypoxemia
but not only that it also can tell you
why why that you know risk why that risk
is low or high so how does it work
so presence system takes as input about
twenty static features this included
surgical procedures or a patient's age a
weight and then a SI code and so on
it also takes real-time features
forty-five or real-time features and
minute-by-minute basis they include a
heart rate or blood oxygen level or
blood pressure and so on okay and then
it makes real-time prediction in the
form of a numeric representation of a
risk or by hypoxemia so in this example
it says a two point five Falls okay two
point five two point four times more
than normal and then not not the current
risk about the ED in the next five
minutes okay and then it's a key feature
is the ability to explain why certain
prediction was made so in this case in
this example it shows that the risk is
due to patient's BMI which by the way is
not modifiable I mean surgery is only
about like a couple of hours here can
you change a BMI and a current tidal
volume so tidal volume means amount of
air exhaled per breath so it's one of
the ventilator settings patients don't
breathe by themselves when they under
anesthesia if they are connected to
ventilator there is a you know you can
adjust a tighter volume there and then
port rate so and then these explanations
it can be clinically meaningful because
some of the factors are modifiable and
then can that can result in clinical
changes so how did we first you know did
build this system so for any machine
learning model as many of you know we
first need some training data and a you
fit the model to the data so our very
supportive collaborators Paula and Jerry
in U SS T GOG they acquired the Ames
data over 50,000 procedures from u-dub
Medical Center and a Harborview Medical
Center and then using this training data
my PhD students Scott learn the various
kinds of a prediction models and they
measured each in models the prediction
performance or new held out data using
cross-validation tests this is very
commonly used approach to measure the
accuracy of a certain prediction model
okay so we did we did that because we
had to choose the best performing model
to begin with so and then we found that
the best - best performing models are
first at the linear regression model
which is a simple model that is very
interpretable the weights will basically
tell you which the features are
important okay and then the best
performing model is a GBM gradient
boosting machine it's a decision tree
ensemble method it's a complex model
it's you eat which it means that it's
often considered as a black box
okay the relationship between features
and then the prediction is not really
clear and then you can see that the tree
ensemble model is significantly better
than the linear model okay this is
actually really big difference in terms
of the ROC curve so actually the machine
learning researchers are very familiar
with this kind of a situation
the trade-off the tension between
accuracy and interpretability
so what it means is that with large
modern complex datasets the best
accuracy is often achieved by complex
models even experts a struggle to
interpret
so complex models of such as a deep
neural network or a tree ensemble tree
model okay and then to resolve this a
challenge we developed a new machine
learning technique to estimate each
features contribution each features
importance for a particular prediction
result so so it's denoted by P 1 through
fie P and then these V values can be
different for different patients and
then we named this approach shot I'm
gonna explain to you what it stands for
later and then it's a general machine
learning framework and it can be applied
to any model any kind of problem you can
you know it doesn't matter whether it's
a tree ensemble model or or a deep
neural network and then it has strong
theoretical properties and then it has a
very rigorous a theoretical you know
grounds and then which I will very
briefly cover in the next few slides but
to us the most exciting aspect of schaap
is the it ability to provide a simple
explanations of predictions from
arbitrarily complex models model
agnostic and then we can eliminate the
typical accuracy and interpretability
trade-off and then that will allow us to
have a broader application of a complex
machine learning model to medicine and
many other application areas so now how
exactly do we estimate this a feature
importance by the way we call it shape
values it stands for shapely additive
explanation values to show that I'm
going to consider a very simple entry
table example ok so it's not about
medicine or you know machine learning at
all it's a very simple example is let me
know if it's not intuitive you know this
is John he's a typical bank customers or
like many customers today when he
applies for a loan his information is
sent through some predictive model and
this model is designed to calculate the
risk that the John will have some
repayment problem which unfortunately is
a 55% and then the bank declines he's a
loan application
okay so here again the natural first
question is why and then again it's AI
magic it's all AI magic whenever you use
the machine learning and and then
there's no explanation so to explain
he's a denier it is important to start
with the base rate over loan repayment
our problem so without any features what
is the chance that you will have a
lonely payment problem so here it's
denoted by the expected value of the
model's output in a to explain john's
risk which is a 55% we need to
understand how to get from the base rate
to the risk over 55% that's the
explanation okay
that's what you want to figure out now
so to do this we started the expected
value of the model output and then we
conditioned on single feature say John's
age and then since this increases John's
risk by 15% and that we attribute that
increase to John's age that's the
importance that you know that's the
importance of the age feature okay so
next we conditioned on John's occupation
which is not almost necessarily in a
stable these days and then we again
attribute that change in D expected the
model output to his occupation as a day
trader okay
so and we repeat this for open account
and the marital status and then we end
up conditioning for all the features and
we arrive at 55% I don't know what it
means maybe like you know the income is
combined when you married so that lowers
the risk risk okay so now we have you
know fifty-five percent right so the you
know the length of the arrow basically
measures the importance of each feature
then are we done you know it's a really
important at this point is that the
order actually matters if it's not it's
not a linear model okay so for instance
the impact of John being a day trader
it could be particularly bad if a young
day trader and that it means that the
impact of a day trader
could be large if you already know that
he's young which is this case so what
that means is that if we reverse the
order between age and occupation it
could be that AG is more important in
the day trader shrinks right so
depending on you know the order of this
introducing features the length of these
arrows can be different so the shaft
values our method it tries to average
these attributions over all possible
orderings how many orderings would it be
and sectoral orderings okay then then
make sense right because there is a non
unique solution then right you consider
all possible orderings and I take
average and then we showed you in our
paper this newest 2017 in case you want
to read in detail in this paper we
showed that these share values are the
only solution they are the only possible
values which maintain three important
properties as a feature attribution
method and these properties are so
important enough that they they make any
comparison among features in terms of
their attributions of meaningful
otherwise it's not meaningful okay and
then this is a unique solution so it's
great but of course you know this is the
this is not how we want to compute the
chef values right and factorial order
you can't really consider n factorial or
a when you have a thousands of features
or hundreds of features you'll be
computationally too much intensive so
the further researching needs to be done
to develop efficient ml algorithms to
compute these share values which my lab
is is actively working on okay so now
let's return to the presence of system
so and we use the DC share values and
then what we want the physicians the
anesthesiologist to see in their time is
the following the risk prediction so in
this case it's 2.5 of all fold risk and
in it explanations with which is you
know these terrible features that
increase the risk the purple colored
features and then
the set of the risk that you know the
green color decrease the risk and then
the plot here at the bottom is
equivalent to rotating the feature
explanation at a certain time point by
90 degrees and then you stack them these
explanations horizontally for each time
point so then you can see the risk trend
and then in this a particular example
the hypoxemia actually happened in the
next five minutes and then if you look
at look at closely
the main factor was a tidal volume
increased you know right before this is
not the point to Martez now okay and
then and then you know that kind of
explanation can give additional
information to the Installer gist to
predict and then you know decide what
action needs to be taken so to test the
potential of a presence to aid hypoxemia
prediction we replayed pre-recorded a
surgery data on we develop some website
and we showed all the data they would
see in the or and then we measure the
anesthesiologist to prediction
performance before and after showing
that that risk prediction so we worked
with a fiber practicing anesthesiologist
and then these are all you know very
experienced very good people from there
most of them are had the professors at
u-dub Hospital and then how it works is
that each anesthesiologist provided a
relative risk of hypoxemia as compared
to the normal acceptable risk for 270
cases and then we you know we let them
score from 1 to 9 so it's like it's not
binary we let them you know score score
the risk and then we averaged their
performance accuracy in the and then
produced the ROC curve so we compared a
group of doctors who predicted without
presence aids so basically this green
card ages to see the data they would see
in the or versus the group of doctors
who saw the whole thing
prediction and then explanations so here
is the difference in terms of the ROC
curve so the prediction accurate
see of anesthesiologist a markedly
improved when they are given the
precedence aid the risk prediction and
its explanation in addition to the
original original the procedure data so
this result suggests that if
anesthesiologists currently anticipate
fifteen percent of the event the y axis
of this ROC curve then you know with the
president's assistant that they could
anticipate thirty percent of the event
so he means like millions of lives
millions of patients per year in the US
so now a natural question is why don't
we just to work you know let the
president's work alone so so
interestingly the prediction performance
of anesthesiologist with President was a
slightly lower so the you see you can
see the purple is just slightly higher
than blue and then you know compared to
the prediction T actually from
precedence
I wouldn't add further comments on this
result let's move on okay so so one next
so we are working on further improving
the prediction accuracy and then we are
focusing on the time series data from a
patient monitoring system so for any
time series data we need some embedding
method to transform the time series real
time series into a form that a machine
learning can take as input and
impression C uses a very simple
exponential average based very simple
approach so we developed the phase
method it's a team learning approach LST
using an STM to carefully extract the
potentially relevant features from time
series and then by using the phase
method we can transfer the embedding
model between hospitals and it turns out
this is a very important fit the
important property because the data
sharing is done very rarely you know
they you know it's a patient privacy
concerns so because of that the
hospitals don't want to share the data
but we can share
the model so here's how it works so by
transferring the embedding model learned
based on some source hospital let's say
the source hospital has lots of data and
that we can potentially improve the
prediction accuracy in a target Hospital
which I say that it has they don't have
that much data so by using this
embedding model learn from source a
hospital you can potentially improve
your prediction performance and here no
data was shared only embedding model was
shared so and then we showed that when
new compared to when you use a de ma
approach your exponential moving average
approach we can improve the prediction
accuracy nearly ten percent okay so and
then independently we are also
developing some machine learning method
to efficiently compute the share values
for a particular model type what did I
say about the the computation time for a
shot value
how many protective order rings n
factorial it's a lot right yeah so it's
not you know it's not practical then so
we are focusing on particular model type
that way we can reduce the computation
significantly so we chose the three
ensembles why trees because it's
extremely popular model especially many
of the cattle competition winners use
2xg boost and it's and fast
implementation of gradient boosting
decision trees and then here is a result
of the Kegel data survey done by a
couple thousand data scientists so three
models are the most widely used is
between logistic regression and you
donate there all three model or ensemble
three models it's you know the most of
widely used models in industries these
days by data scientists so we designed
three algorithms that can reduce exact
computation of a shape values from
exponential to polynomial time and then
I will show you in the next slides that
this enables exciting applications okay
so then you know as a part of this a
tree shape work we developed a rich
visualized visual visual representation
of the global importance of the features
across many patients
and then we call it shap summary plot so
how does it work so we to explore this
visualization we use that enhance data
from hundred thousand individuals who
were interviewed and then tested in that
nineteen 1970's followed up for twenty
years it's a long longitudinal study and
then we extracted fourteen common
measurements and demographic values and
the front blood tests and they we used
them as a features to predict survivor
the deaths in the next twenty minutes
using Cox proportional hazards model
okay and for each patient after training
you know the prediction model for each
individual we computed the shaft values
each one will have a different you know
prediction result and then it will have
a different reasons different
explanations and then what you can do
with all these toughy values those are
shaft values is that for each feature
you can you can show the distribution of
their values so you you can you know
collect all these V values and then and
then draw the you know plot in the right
side of the slide so here you know there
are lots of dots each dot is a patient
and then touch represented you know
share values of this all patients and
then they are plotted horizontally
depending on the shaft values you can
see it is the x-axis on the bottom and
then you can stack them vertically when
you're out of the space to show the
density so basically this is like a
violin plot but you don't have to worry
about our arbitrary choice of the
kernels and so on and then you color
each dot by the value of that feature
from low blue to hi red so we can see
you know unsurprisingly their age is the
most important risk factor for this over
the next twenty years not surprising at
all and then overall many features show
long tails reaching to the right and
then not that much to the left so let's
see this is systolic blood pressure
feature
then it only has a large impact for
minority / people with high blood
pressure if you focus on just two red
dots they are all in the right side okay
there you know they contribute hugely to
death and then you know this general
trend means that the extreme values of
these measurements can significantly
raise your risk of death but cannot you
know significantly lower your risk so in
other words there are many ways to die
younger but there are not that many ways
you know to be out of a range and then
live longer okay so sad but that's what
you have so many plot can show okay
alright so now let's focus on each
individual feature and then we can use a
shamble use to create some you know rich
alternative to a partial dependents plot
which we term chap dependence plot so
how does it work
so it uses a shape values of a
particular feature now I'm focusing on
just the systolic blood pressure for you
know the we plot their shape values
individual shape values in the y-axis
and then the value of the feature in the
x-axis each dot is an individual okay a
person and then by planning these values
for many individuals from the data set
we can see you know how these are
features attributed important changes
over each own values okay over you know
as its value it varies so while standard
pressure dependence plot only producer
lines the shaft dependence plot captures
a vertical dispersions this is caused by
interaction effect in the model and then
this effect can be visualized by
coloring each dot with the value of
another feature that has the largest
interacting the the own interacting
feature so coloring by age shows that
high blood pressure is more alarming
when you are young okay and it's
presumably because it takes time for
high blood pressure to lead to fatal
complications it makes perfect sense
medically
and then we can this decomposed the
shaft dependence plot into main effect
an interaction effect okay and it's all
described in detail in our our
manuscript which I believe we made it
available in archive so this is a very
interesting one Schaap monitoring plot
so you know what happens when you deploy
a machine learning model in practice
like everything else sometimes it breaks
so what's worth when it plays it often
just to get a less accurate and so you
might never even notice even though
there is a problem okay so for instance
let's say that you deploy the model
train to predict the duration of the
surgeries so before the surgery you have
information about the patient and then
you want to predict the iteration of the
surgery it is a very important problem
for scheduling of ours so if we are
careful data scientists your monitor the
average performance over time so why
accessing you can see the MSE the error
okay and then the x-axis is the
deployment time okay so I'm showing you
know you so you are seeing now two years
of the deployment and I mean he seems to
oscillate randomly over two years and
then you would never know you know just
by looking at this plot there is a
problem but we actually did something
wrong so we intentionally introduced an
error after one year of deployment we
swapped the labor of the two rooms in
the hospital
oh not your hospital just a data it will
be a crime if he's actually you know
suits up the room okay so so this is
shared monitoring plot decompose the
models loss we are not talking about
prediction right now we are talking
about the loss okay
and then we decompose among each of the
features and then this allows us to see
the impact of each of our features on
the models loss over time so here we see
the plot y OD the chap values of the
loss for one of the mislabeled rooms and
then it identifies a clear increase in
move in the model model error
exactly when does this miss lane
happened so this tells us three
important things we didn't previously
know about first is that there is a
problem problem exists and then second
which feature is causing the problem
gloom rainbows and then third how much
that problem is impacting our models of
performance and then we believe that
these types of monitoring plots can help
improve our ability to safely deploy
models in practice it's not just applied
to medicine like many other applications
as well okay
so in the first part of the talk I
presented our Shapp method and then with
that enables individualized explanations
of a prediction and then let's turn to
the second topic so second and third are
each of them is very short so second one
is about cancer precision medicine so
what does that mean so say that there is
a patient EXO who has AML it's an
aggressive blood cancer and they're like
other cancers there are many anti-cancer
drugs this patient can be treated with
but standardly cancer therapy is not
personalized so our goal is to peel the
machine learning based system that takes
molecular profile of a patient so it's
like you know molecular profile
misdirect Facebook profile so some
individual you know some persons
information and then in particular we
are focusing on the gene expression data
there are 20,000 human genes and then
you can measure the activity level we
call it expression level for each
individual gene and we call them
expression data and then you want to
select the best you know drug based on
the prediction of the response predicted
response and then not only that we also
want to give explanation why oppression
is going to respond well to a particular
drug based on that we want us physicians
to choose the best combination of drugs
or for a particular patient so the you
know it turns out that the first one
learning a robust the prediction model
is actually really hard it was you know
does you have a experience with high
dimensional molecular data it's you know
the learning
prediction model itself is really hard
the problem so it can be you know seen
as a classic supervised learning problem
and looks easy so you know for instance
you have a training data now you are
have the training data from hematologist
now which you know consists of the
feature variables in this case
expression levels over 20,000 genes and
then you have outcome variables Y which
is drug sensitivity measures for 160
drugs so how it works is that we take
out the cancer cells outside of the
patient body and they put it on de Pedra
petri dish and we call you know we use
each of the drugs and then see how many
cancer cells die because each drug is a
designed to kill faster growing cells
and then we and then what we can do is
they using this training data we learn
some prediction model for each of these
drugs so that when we have a new patient
with expression data we want to predict
the drug sensitivity look so really
simple so we first evaluated this a
simplest form of the supervised to
learning approach by measuring how many
of the significant gene drug pairwise
associations like correlation observed
in the training data are actually
replicated in an independent and
validation data set to make sure that we
don't overt it that much so my student
Sofia
computed the consistency rate basically
defined as you know associations are
replicated and independent data divided
by the number of significant
associations and they can be viewed as a
true discovery rate you want this rate
to be high okay we ordered the list of
gene drug pairs depending on the degrees
of association and then we got really
depressing result only 18% is an 18
percent yeah 18 percent of the
association's who are replicated
independent data set this is actually a
really common problem especially when
you use high dimensional data you simply
don't have enough statistical power
enough samples to identify the
through positive associations and the
second confounders there are hidden
variables and they say that there is a
hidden variable there is a true
predictor for a certain drug and I say
that it happens to be associated with a
bunch of genes in your training data
that creates indirect Association
compared to this association and then
this indirect path ok these associations
may not be replicated in independent
data set another possibility is that say
that there is a true predictor for a
certain drug say that that gene is a
disease driver important gene in the
disease and then it regulates lots of
other genes which creates correlations
significant association with many other
genes expression that again creates
indirect Association so there is a
discrepancy between October association
and then true biological model so
supervised to approach is not the way to
go so we developed an unsupervised
feature learning approach to selected
genes that are actually likely to
explain the association's so here is how
it works we use lots of a publicly
available data set from any AML patient
and then we created a gene level
features I mean you're gonna see why we
named the merge soon so for each gene we
counted how many times how frequently
that gene is mutated DNA mutation causes
cancer so if some gene is highly mutated
in a my patient it means that the gene
is likely to be driver of the disease
which is likely to be reliable predictor
for drug there are purely response and
then we also have another vector that
measures how likely that gene is a hub
energy Network and then whether the gene
is known to regulate other genes and
then it has copy number aberrations and
the methylated so picking up each of
this letter we named a merger feature
it's basically a merging publicly
available data set to help our problem
of predicting drug sensitivity so our AI
algorithm can automatically learn which
features are important and I create just
one score for each gene we named them
merge score which
can explain the association level how
you know popular that gene for how you
know predictive that gene is a for many
can anti-cancer drugs and they by doing
that and then here you know the point is
that we want to focus on explainable
associations not just a random
Association so we showed that that
significantly increases the replication
rate and then also we compared the with
state over the art machine learning
algorithm to predict drug sensitivity
and they show that it does it better it
paper was published in Nature
communications earlier last year last
last year
okay so many of the you know gene drug
pairs identified by the merge algorithm
made a lot of sense
Facebook known AML biology and then one
of the novel findings though is D a gene
called SMA RCA for we admitted smoker
for okay so disappointing is really
important so basically what this you
know figure means is that this smoker
for gene expression levels are highly
predictive of a sensitivity to to drugs
mitoxantrone and at top aside okay and
then this finding is really important
because these are true drugs are
actually actively used in AML treatment
and then this is maca for gene would
have never been captured if your
analysis was based on supervisor
learning approach I mean they are highly
ranked but not as much as like top you
know not so merged you know ranked this
gene is like a top gene but there was a
lot of other genes if you just focus on
just correlation level association level
so our collaborator in hematology was a
super motivated to experimentally
validate this hypothesis in her lab so
we picked cell population they
originally show Louis maca for and then
we transfected these cells to show high
smoker for level so the difference
between these two cell populations is
that you know one population has a low
smoker for the other one is a high
smoker for so how does that change the
drug sensitivity so
to standard a dose-response curve x-axis
is drug concentration y-axis is how many
cells are still alive so what this graph
shows is that when smoker for expression
is high the genes the drug can kill
these cells more effectively and then
just to be sure that this is a real we
also tested another a Mercer line they
originally show the high smoker for
expression transfected it and then the
drug sensitivity stays the same and then
some day I really want you know I hope
that this my collaborator we tested this
in clinic through clinical trial so you
know you can see smoker for expression
level of the patient and decide whether
to treat the patient with these drugs
and then see actual meaningful of
increase in survivor time so in the
second part of the talk we talked about
choosing drugs and personalize the drug
recommendations are only possible when
you have a drugs to choose from which is
unfortunately not true for the case of
Alzheimer's disease so how many of you
are familiar with our services probably
all right so it's a number six leading
cause of death and in the only disease
among the top ten deadly disease in the
US that has a no cure no prevention and
there's no treatment to reverse or
Hardys progression and then critical
barriers is that we don't know much
about the molecular basis for
Alzheimer's disease pathology there are
neuropathology core hallmarks that they
define the Alzheimer's disease amyloid
to play and then tangos we call them
plaques and tangles okay and then their
basic building blocks are a beta and
then tau respectively and then you know
we often learn about the molecular basis
for phenotype so neuropathology Corvina
thousand tau and a beta are phenotypes
by using gene expression data and then
the phenotype data in this case it will
be neuropathy logical phenotype so how
does it work so
from one human brain you can code you
can measure the a beta level and then
you can also measure the expression
levels of the 20,000 genes another brain
many other brains you can measure the
same things now you have a set of
samples and then you can find the genes
or relevant to the phenotype by
measuring the Association statistical
association between each gene and then
it's in then the phenotype and then you
know the genes that are significantly
associated with these a beta they are
potentially the genes that are important
in Alzheimer's disease okay so my
student Sofia she started with
collecting these expression and then a
beta data from you know various parts of
the brain in collaboration with our Turk
Paul and then and then Joey and then we
ended up finding data from three
Alzheimer's studies so to our knowledge
you know this is the largest expression
analysis for Alzheimer's disease so we
analyzed the basically 1,700 samples
from nine brain regions but the approach
I just described to you this correlation
approach is not going to work because
different brain regions have a different
cell type composition different roles so
there are potential confounders there
and then you know different tools and
methods were used when you measure the a
beta for three different studies and
then there are many you know vectors
that you know that make the data nosy so
we need a super powerful machine
learning approach that can incorporate
you know the reliable prior knowledge in
biology to help us to focus on the true
signals so what did we do about that so
we use the pathway data set so what it
means is that we have a big matrix
columns are pathways rows our genes for
each gene you have some kind of a
membership pathway based on a lot of a
biological knowledge so here the
assumption is that the
jeans that are in the same pathway when
one of them has association with a beta
all the others may also are likely to
have association with a beta only then
you were to trust their association okay
so we developed some hierarchical
Bayesian approach that's going to
produce as you know a gene level
relevance vector so this alpha vector it
tells you how much a gene is related to
a beta phenotype and then beta which is
a pathway level relevance it's you know
number tells you well how much that
pathway is related to a beta we applied
it to our nine dataset and then cut the
result that says that in terms of
pathway this pathway is the most
important for a beta and that these
genes are tab listed and then and that
we made a hypothesis that some Sara
genes named and duf we invidious end of
end off okay end of gene families many
genes are in the end of families are
related are relevant to this a beta
phenotype so next step was that we used
transgenic C elegans so this you know
these worms they are like one millimeter
in length and then we you know have a
very good collaborators that have a
transgenic C elegans they are not normal
worms they have basically Alzheimer's
they produce a beta human a beta in
their muscle cells so it's age
associated so in their you know life
spent at some point they are paralyzed
because a beta is a very bad protein
okay so the question is if you then you
know perturb those genes if you say you
know knock down this end of end of gene
then would that delay the paralysis so
would that make you know make it better
make them healthier so to test that we
worked with met cable ins group in you
know pathology and then it is called the
paralysis essay so he has this cool
robot system that enables this kind of
experiment one
and read you know for testing you know
at the same time for 100 genes and then
it's called a Warren bud system and then
and then we used to basically you know
RNA I to reduce the expression of this
end of a gene we pick the one that has
the highest alpha value which is end of
a nine and then worm also has you know
corresponding gene and then the question
is whether we will observe a significant
delay in paralysis
so how would it actually look so here is
the idea so so here is the set of words
not treated they have a tea and then
treatment means that you reduce the
expression level of end of an I so and
then it's a festival so you can see that
you know as the time goes the worms in
on that test site are treated three
little worms and more more lively right
and it's a consistent with the disk rep
percentage worms and moving so it's you
know paralysis it's a visually very
clear that paralysis was delayed right
okay are they gone okay yeah so that's
the idea so so our question then is what
about other genes in this end of family
so we tested the other of twelve other
genes the named end of and then actually
they are you know the genes that form
larger protein they are called it's
called like complex one protein they are
important in mitochondrial function
metabolism and then all of them turning
down you know the knocking down each of
them all all of them you know show the
delay the paralysis so what does that
mean that means that you know our method
pinpointed it is a complex one as some
you know potential drug target for
Alzheimer's disease so so so is there a
drug that is known to inhibit complex
one yeah
if there is already a drug that all you
know inhibit this we don't have to
develop another drug right we can just
repurpose that drug so there is a you
know there are several drugs one of them
is a caps I seen
so you know red peppers have a lot of
capsizing so we haven't tested with a
capsize in yet but it may be a good idea
to start eating more peppers okay so in
this talk so I presented our new
interpretable machine learning
techniques chef's and more and then you
also you know I showed the merge in and
then this last you know we actually
named it embark our method empirical you
know Bayesian something approach and
then you know we I showed that they can
potentially change the way we treat
patients and then make meaningful
biological discoveries from big data and
then you know I believe that this
exemplified the importance of advancing
AI and ml we think that you know AI and
ml are so powerful but still they are
not perfect and then they can actually
lead to you know very high impact
advancing AI can lead to high impact in
medicine and biology so okay so last
slide so I want to thank my PhD student
in the Allen school and then MD ph.d
program the students who were brave
enough to choose a computer science as a
PhD major and then we were working with
the extremely supportive and strong
group of medical investigators at the
University of Washington and then last
not the least lot over you know funding
support that you know support generously
supported my lab what each funding
agency helped us with a different amount
of money but I like I really like all of
them and I'm thankful thank you
thank you for the fantastic talk any
questions yeah so you correctly
mentioned a generalized treatment for
individual patients ancient the
generalized treatment for individual
patients and complex diseases can lead
to devastating effects you talked about
sharing models between models between
hospitals instead of actual patient data
because hospitals are more reluctant to
share actual data yeah my question is
what's what's the disconnect between
hospitals sharing like individual blood
work or B I mean basic patient MRIs or
scans like that what's the disconnect if
you can like between sharing it in an
anonymous fashion like why are hospitals
not being able to we think that if we do
identify the patient we can share the
data easily okay yeah but they are I
mean we think so right because it's not
human subject anymore right but it's you
know it's in practice it's it's actually
really hard you have to go through you
know a few other approval steps to
actually get you know get the medical
data even if for you t identify the
patient yeah and even through this a
collaboration we I have never worked on
identifiable data at all my collaborator
or you know they identify the data first
and they send them to us yeah so it
depends you know if it said I post
hospitals are you double Philly 18 for
instance I you the medical center and
then hover be hospital it makes it you
know a lot easier but say like you dub
Hospital hub Harvard Medical School and
yeah in that case it's it becomes a hard
but there are also public sources public
datasets as well often the imagery
resolution may not be the best but you
know there are various sources but in
general you know it's a people you know
feel really reluctant to about sharing
their medical data yeah
question is regarding so the idea of
using mm AI for you know this broader
area of medicine and cancer and so on
has been talk for now almost a decade
sort of educate us a little bit what has
concretely come out from a sign side
that is being actively followed through
from that line of research I mean what
do the top genetics or the people who
are the cutting edge of the core science
how they're following up or you know I
would be interested to know the
interaction between the two subfields so
so machine learning paper on medical
diagnosis what we have seen those papers
like 10 years over like many years ago
right yes there was a whole you know
article in JAMA it's a top medical
journal about why machine learning why
it wasn't you know deployed at that
point I you I think that the explica
explanation is it makes it hard for the
the you know physicians to actually use
this sort of a system so when you see
just a prediction alone versus you know
when you also see the suggested reasons
I think a left let go interpretability
and then explain ability isn't one
really you know important I mean there
was also you know whatever the points
made by that article so make making them
believable you know I think it's a
really important way to make um you know
this machine learning system actually
deployed in hospitals and also another
thing we have to address is the
actionability
now we can see these explanations we can
use a chef right but then you know how
do the doctor have to act on it I mean
you know like this is share values
between your actionability and then
explain ability there's a difference
between them right
which was not about the doctor but about
the people understanding our sinus
disease which really has nothing to do
with the physicians themselves say tell
us to do it the scientists in the who
understands genetics and understand
right my question was with that they are
following up on this or what has
happened in the last decade when we you
know not just your work but you know
broadly the community was trying to sort
of get into how to solve cancer and
other things yeah well ours emergency in
particular there is a no drug that is
known to be effective right and then you
know the major bottle leg was their lack
of understanding we don't know you know
you don't understand biology of it and
endure one of the reasons for that is
the lack of data because we don't need
without any you know brain expression or
like genetic data in fact you know
Alzheimer's is a highly it's not very
genetic and then that means you need to
brain tissues and that means that you
need a frozen tissue collected it
directly from your I mean to some Auto C
brain there is in good condition right
and then he became only available only
very recently yeah that's it there was a
major bottleneck which confusion was
important you think of the other side I
think what I heard that if you didn't
you don't believe it because sometimes
they're a systemic addiction seems very
simple should we write this incorrect I
think to explain why is predictive long
it's very important for the trust water
system right yeah it's one of the future
future directions we want to focus all
right yeah so the explanations will be
helpful to explain your prediction rizzo
it also helps you identify errors right
sometimes they you know machine and
prediction is wrong and then if the
reason explanations don't make any sense
then it can help you identify the
mistake right am i answering your
question yeah
don't you found why you made a mistake
that's white actually it's correcting
right because based on the experience of
the human you know whether right or
wrong but then the machine when the
protector wrong something is no why
that's that's a really good point yeah
and then the chat monitoring plot can be
applied to that problem right cuz yeah
could it tries to find a reason for loss
yeah I mean I have a short question so I
think I'm really impressed about the
ship value how like how ready is the the
implementation of the ship in like
general popular at some point we already
have a gas hog I mean we're already
about the current version over the
algorithm anyone can you know download
it just you know googled shape and then
github but the technical problem we are
trying to address is that when the
features are correlated it can confuse
the shape method right in feature a and
B are highly correlated each other say
that they are like almost identical
feature that and the attribution will be
divided right yeah so that's the you
know that one of the technical issues
only problem challenges we try to
address okay yeah thanks but the current
version is it just it's there even the
Trisha is also ready to be used
[Applause]